[Musique]
et les instruments qui coûte le moins
cher
bon un instrument de base ne coûte pas
trop cher donc un enfant que se faire
offrir lors des fêtes de noël
un harmonica donc c'est comme ça que
j'ai commencé avec un harmonica de bas
de gamme
et puis après quand j'ai puis le mes
poches acheter des harmonicas donc j'ai
acheté des harmonicas un peu plus
sophistiquée d'harmonica diatonique et
chromatique mais monica aussi avec
plusieurs tonalités exactement
l'harmonica chromatique c'est
l'harmonica comme le piano qui permet de
vous tous les morceaux avec les
altérations donc comme celui que j'ai là
l'harmonica
celui là c'est l'harmonie cadeaux comme
le piano donc les notes blanches sont là
sans appuyer qu'on appuie sur la tirette
on allait les touches noires c'est à
dire les altérations diez et bémol et
les autres tonalité c'est vous permettre
de
une facilité plus de facilités pour
pouvoir accompagner certains musiciens
puisque jouer avec un seul harmonica
dans toutes les tonalités c'est pas
chose comme mode
[Musique]
la fête de l'harmonica pour les
harmonicistes ou ce vraiment qu'ils
aiment l'harmonica c'est une occasion
une bonne occasion de jouer avec des
musiciens confirmés tels lopes musaïcos
avec lequel de manuel ceinture avec
lequel on va se produire jeudi
jeudi soir donc c'est pour nous une
occasion en fois trop rare de s'exprimer
convenablement